tenemos la siguiente figura que es algo
así como redondo que hemos visto ya
varias veces y vamos a pensar en algo
que sucede si yo parto esta pieza o este
éste este entero qué pasa si yo parto
esto a la mitad
en dos partes iguales
ahora tengo dos mitades o dos medios si
yo llego a dibujar uno de estos digamos
con azul tendré una mitad o un medio y
ahora dibujaré la otra mitad tendré dos
medios y un claro que tenemos aquí esta
división ok entonces tenemos de las dos
posibilidades
de los dos medios ahora tengo en color
azul dos de ellas
lo que significa que tengo un entero dos
medios son un entero vamos a colocar eso
un entero
tengo las dos partes dibujadas en azul
que pasa si tengo exactamente la misma
figura
y esta vez la dividir en tres partes
iguales
si este es el centro vamos a dibujar
tres partes iguales
quedó bastante bien parece un símbolo de
mercedes tenemos ahora dividido este
gran círculo en tres partes iguales y
dibujaré estas partes del círculo
ahora en verde tengo una un tercio
dos tercios
tres tercios he dibujado con el color
verde
tres de esos tres tercios tres de las
tres posibilidades que tenían tres
tercios también lo puedo llamar como un
entero porque porque estoy dibujando en
color verde el círculo completo que
tenía tendremos entonces también un
entero y vamos a hacer esto todavía un
poquito más evidente vamos a colocar una
más
y si yo divido este círculo completo en
una sola parte pensaré en color rojo si
yo divido todo éste entero en una sola
parte pues ya no tenía / es un entero
completo y si todo esto lo dibujo
con el color rojo
y entonces habré coloreado de ese entero
posible
de una sola parte igual posible el
coloreado de rojo una de estas partes
por lo tanto también lo puedo llamar un
entero y aquí es mucho más obvio
que lo he dibujado completamente y estoy
segura que ustedes ya notaron aquí el
patrón que estamos siguiendo si de las
dos partes iguales que tengo yo tomo
esas dos entonces estaré tomando uno
entero o de la misma manera de las tres
posibles partes iguales
si tomo tres de esas partes entonces
estaré tomando un entero de la misma
manera aquí tomé el 100% o tome uno de
la única parte que será posible de esta
manera tenemos un entero y lo podemos
ver también en nuestra recta numérica
voy a hacer una recta numérica que vaya
del 0
al 1
y bueno se puede seguir ustedes ya saben
que esto se puede seguir y vamos a
representar cada una de estas fracciones
dentro de la recta numérica tomaremos en
el color azul el primer ejemplo entonces
están diciendo que tenemos dos medios es
decir que del 0 al 1 estaremos partiendo
nuestra
a distancia en dos partes posibles dos
partes iguales la primera y la segunda
tenemos entonces ya dividido en dos
partes iguales 1 2 nos dice nos dicen
que avanzaremos esas dos partes
así es que daremos un brinco 1
y daremos el brinco 2
hemos llegado al entero al 1 qué pasa si
tengo entonces todo esto dividido en
tres partes iguales vamos a dividir del
0 al 1 en tres partes iguales tenemos 1
3 ok de esas 3 partes iguales
nos dicen que avanzaremos 3 partes
así es que daremos un saltito uno otro
salto dos y el último salto será el
número tres
perfecto hemos llegado otra vez al 1 a
un entero y finalmente si nosotros
tenemos dividido nuestra recta del 0 al
1 en un gran espacio del 0 al 1 como lo
teníamos originalmente el 0 al 1 brink
haremos una sola vez para llegar a esta
fracción
así es queremos este salto
y llegamos exactamente al 1 así es que
dos medios tres tercios o uno de uno son
diferentes formas de llamar a un entero
o al número uno